maybe there's like a giant travis scott  concert whatever there's going to be  violence on the african continent uh  continent like like barack obama what a  project  i'm like oh geez that's never happened  before he's stabbing people with a  fentanyl yeah with a super whatever is  that what happened to travis scott  who knows but they're saying it's like a  super possibility for a super friend no  because fentanyl wasn't strong enough  what if you're like i just i can't be  carrying these rice grain sized amounts  of fat no what am i a pack mule yeah  it's like it's like a cereal commercial  for kids where it's like there was a  problem at the fentanyl factory what now  it's whoops all fat now it's mini fit  now oh no yeah there's so much fentanyl